the only way you can have change you get
people into the streets is when they
lose faith in the system and we have to
get them we have to disabuse them of the
idea that there is somebody fighting for
them in this system and there isn't so
so you so I was going to ask you what's
the solution you you just said the
solution is to get people to lose faith
in the system for a part of it and get
the streets to lose faith in the system
okay so let's just say let's let's play
that let's let's say that happens okay
let's say somehow somewhere AOC and
Bernie Sanders listen to this and they
have a change of heart and they said
Jimmy you're right and they tweet out on
Twitter today and they say Jimmy's right
okay let's take it on the streets and
let's go everywhere and let's protest
against this fantastic then what
uh that's when we that's how things
change that's how we got civil rights
what should change that's how women got
the right what should change what so
when we get money out of politics is the
first thing we got to get money out of
politics and so it's the 100 we I I
would recommend uh public financing of
our elections and we shorten our
election season all there's a million
things you could do that way but
definitely get money out of politics you
want to have election uh campaign
Finance reform right that's number one
on your list that'll never change that
would be so that's what I mean until we
shut stuff down I mean the truckers
showed that you could bring them to your
need their needs and in Canada yeah yeah
and so and you know of course people in
the United States they listen to the
corporate media they call those people
Nazis when they're actually Freedom
Fighters and they were right they
weren't fighting against medicine the
truckers were vaccinated at a higher
rate than the general population in
Canada they were fighting against
authoritarianism and they were right and
America look at those truckers and they
call them Nazis and they look at Nazis
in Ukraine and they call them Freedom
Fighters that's how messed up our
corporate media is Jimmy so let's but
let's go with that I'll tell you one
more thing I want you to keep going
though so give me more sorry that was
very good point but keep going so what
happened in Staten Island at the Amazon
warehouse Christian Smalls is a black
guy who got fired and then he decided to
uh organize a union and he organized
along class lines so a lot of people on
the left in the Democratic party said we
have to organize along class lines they
don't mean it because what organizing
along class lines means is you're going
to organize with trumpers you're going
to organize with because you're in the
same class and that's exactly what
Christian Smalls did on Staten Island
you know you know Staten Island is a
bunch of trump voters and so he went and
organized those people because they have
a common interest and they have they
have a they have a a common enemy and
that is the establishment and the
oligarchy and you put it down your your
differences politically and you join
together on a class basis and you uh
that's how you make change and so we
need more of that we need more people
coming together unless the left and the
right realize that we do have common
interests which we do we want to we all
want to stop the war machine we all want
to stop this authoritarianism around
kovid we all want to stop a lot of
things right so if we could come
together and realize we're being screwed
because our government is a hundred
percent corrupt then maybe we could get
get something done you know
um I had a Boogaloo boy on my show now a
lot of people conflate Boogaloo boys
with proud boys but they're not Boogaloo
boys are a response to the proud boys
Boogaloo boys we're a pro lgbtq they
were pro-black lives matter they're
anti-war they were anti-trump and they
were anti uh cop
so I'm like oh my God that's we agree on
a lot of things I didn't know that well
they can't so the establishment the
Democratic party they did a smear
campaign against me they still do it to
this day just because I interviewed a
Boogaloo boy on my show I didn't I
didn't hire him I didn't go we just had
an interview just like you're
interviewing me that doesn't mean you're
you know you're validating what I'm
saying you're just interviewing me same
thing so that's house and that is the
thing that scares them if the left and
the right organize on class lines that
is the thing that we're really scared
we're doing an anti-war rally on the
19th this Sunday at the Lincoln Memorial
in in Washington DC and we got people
from the left we got people from the
right we got people from the center we
got all kinds of people to oppose War
that's what gives it its power if it was
just a bunch of progressive lefties it
wouldn't have any power but the fact
that there's Ron Paul's going to be
there he's going to be speaking so
that's a big deal and Tulsi gabard's
gonna be there and uh beginning Ron Paul
out of Houston yeah he never he never
leaves Texas this is a big deal that
he's gonna to be here so anyway that's
we have to do more things like that
that's the only way to take back our
government is to get in the streets shut
stuff down and you know in France uh
they have eight they have their they're
going to try to raise their retirement
age from 61 to 63. you know they're
raising it in the United States is 67.
they they already have Medicare for all
they already have dental they have
retirement social security and they
still get in the streets and shut [__]
down all the time and I don't know if
you've ever been uh we were in Italy it
was like oh the trains aren't going to
be running today there's going to be a
strike they do it all the time wearing
back Mussolini in the rest of the world
the left is connected to the working
class except in the United States the
Democratic party is a bunch of their
their core constituency are Suburban
white people that they they admitted it
Chuck Schumer said they go hey when
Hillary was running against Donald Trump
they were saying hey Donald Trump's
picking up blue collar voters and he
said doesn't matter for every
blue-collar voter we lose we're gonna
pick up two or three white collar
Suburban voters and you can repeat that
in Ohio and Wisconsin he said that I
have I played on my show all the time of
course he was wrong he they lost and so
they don't care about the blue collar
voters they don't care about the workers
that's not their constituency
that's why there's nobody representing
them anymore that's right that's what
gave Donald Trump his power because he
spoke to those people Jimmy who's
anti-establishment today on the left or
the right who's anti-establishment today
left right middle libertarian who are
some of the names Ron Paul being one of
them who else would you say I'm you know
I don't have any faith in any of the
politicians right now there's a woman in
Seattle shama Sawan uh she had to fight
the Democratic mayor in the Democratic
City councils to get a 15 minimum wage
she has to fight the Democrats to get
stuff the Democrats and the Republicans
serve the same people they have the same
neoliberal corporate interests and so I
don't I don't I don't know anybody in
politics that I would really uh go away
so who I used to like Rokon I used to
like AOC I used to like all those Bernie
Sanders but none of them will stand up
for what they claim to stand for and
they all roll over for the establishment
they all voted for war
but Jimmy okay so let's say not politics
who outside of politics because you need
some of the guys that are from the
outside to get in the inside like people
like Chris Hedges I like Paul Dennis
kucinich is out of politics right they
they so he was they gerrymandered him
out right the Democrats are like f you
you're you're too much of a progressive
and they get rid of him and then he's
done so um I I don't I like people like
Chris Hedges I like people like Dennis
kucinich I loved the way Tulsi stood up
against the war machine in Syria uh
unfortunately she's still for the Drone
program but so what she's better than
everybody else on when it comes to
cereal and that's why they people don't
realize why they hated uh uh Tulsi so
much is because she stepped down from
the being the vice chair of the
Democratic National Committee to endorse
Bernie Sanders so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]